hello Dr Kutcher here doctor spelled
with an ER not an or I'm here to give
relationship advice and based on my
history of doctoral
exceptionalism I have all kinds of
relationship advice that I am willing
and able to share
so let us begin session
welcome to the couch question number one
how do I tell
my longtime friend of 15 years that I'm
in love with them Dr Kutcher doctor with
an ER
um I don't think you should tell your
friend to 15 years that you're in love
with them you haven't started dating
that person yet under the guise of it
being romantic so my suggestion would be
actually say to the person and
articulate to them I want to date you
romantically
don't tell them that you're in love with
them
because you're not in love with them
romantically yet you're in love with
them as friends my other suggestion
would be try kissing them first before
you say that you're in love with them
you know the old first comes love then
comes marriage then comes baby in the
baby carriage the love uh part can come
before the marriage part and the saying
I love you part question number two for
Dr Kutcher doctor with an ER how do you
know if someone is the one any tips on
where and when to propose that's two
questions so whoever this uh reader is
is really trying to like pack in their
questions if you don't know they're not
the one that's how you know you're
asking yourself the question if you're
like is this person the one if the
definitive answer to that isn't yes
they're probably not the answer is
probably no maybe usually means no
very important thing question number two
from the same person who's taking up
BuzzFeed Question Time tips on where to
propose here's what I would suggest
proposing in a place
that is Meaningful to your partner or
there's a distinct memory you have of
your love and care for one another in
that place that could be a very good
place to return to for a proposal dear
Dr Kutcher doctor with an ER how do I
initiate sexy time with my wife without
feeling like I'm bothering her and I
don't know why I went to aboret with my
wife foreplay for women it happens all
day long it's not like right before
you're ready to have sex before play
begins and it's not wild when you're
having sex or making out with foreplay
starts like in the morning and have
foreplay happen all day long so that by
the time it it's time for sexy time
um the foreplay has already happened why
doesn't my significant other post about
me on social media I post about them all
the time but even when I ask them to
share photos of us they won't it might
not be me meaningful to them at all
posting on social media or they might
not want others to know about your
relationship if your fear is they don't
want others to know about your
relationship that's an entirely
different thing and it's not relative to
social media if the answer to that is
yes you have a sense that they are
secure in your relationship then maybe
posting on social media and broadcasting
the relationship just isn't their love
language any tips to keep relationships
strong when you work long hours and have
kids
that
is a million dollar question for Dr
Kutcher doctor with an ER every week
have a date night that is your time and
flip every other week the other person
has to plan where you're going to go
what you're going to do try to surprise
because surprise is powerful because
when we're surprised it drops dopamine
into our bodies and that's like a
natural drug that we all get to take
whenever we get surprised and it's
lovely and feels nice it doesn't have to
be going out it could be like hey we're
gonna paint each other tonight which is
weird to think about doing but could be
a fun date night uh or hey we're gonna
do like a mini bonfire and a coffee can
on our balcony don't set the building on
fire I think there are four parts in a
relationship that you used to talk about
and it's okay to grade each other on one
is romance sexy times two is your
friendship three is how you uh are
roommates and four is uh how you are as
co-parents use that time to continue to
elevate your relationship that's my
advice today this is Dr Kutcher doctor
with an ER signing off thank you
BuzzFeed check out your place of mine on
Netflix I think you'll enjoy it and keep
your hearts open
[Music]